In your first programming class, computer memory may have been
explained to you with a picture that looks something like this.
We have the CPU, where your instructions get executed, and these
instructions may read or write to either main Memory, or to
Disk. Main memory is Fast, and you can access any element
in the same amount of time. That's what we mean by
Random Access. And it is Temporary in the sense that when
the program exits or if power is lost, all the information
stored in it disappears. The hard disk, by contrast, is
slow. It uses Sequential Access since you have to actually
spin the disk to the right place. And what you
write to the disk is permanent. It will still be there
when the program exits or if power is lost. In
this lecture, we're going to refine this picture in two ways. First,
we'll look at Cache Systems, which allow the CPU to
access the same information that is in main memory, only faster.
Understanding how cache systems work will help you optimize your
code when you need to. Second, we will explain the Virtual
Memory system. As you write your application and compiler compiles it
to generate addresses for all your variables and your code, you
don't have to worry about other programs and what memory
addresses they might be using. In fact there's often an illusion
that having even more main memory then exists in the system,
and that your application has them all to yourself. W'll see
how the operating system maintains this abstraction
to the virtual memory system. The details are
essential to understanding operating systems optimizations. And how
the need to share resources affects program performance.